la première question va être posée par
le groupe rassemblement national par
l'intermédiaèire de Monsieur Roger
chudau
oui
merci merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre de l'Éducation nationale ma
question porte sur la carte scolaire du
prer
degré tout comme vos 15 glorieux
prédéceur vous affirmez que
l'enseignement des fondamentaux est la
priorité des priorités votre
prédécesseur le plus bref désormais
Premier ministre déclare avec de mals
accents que l'éducation est la mère des
batailles comment justifier alors les
179 suppressions de postes dans le
premier degré public inscrite au budget
2024 l'Association des maires de France
celle des maires ruraux les les
départements font remonter à tous les
députés de vives protestation à ce sujet
il s'agite évidemment des département de
cette France périphérique France oubliée
France méprisée par l'oligarchie
macronienne
dans mon département de Loir et Cher 24
suppressions après 17 l'an passé et le
recteur annonce que ça n'est pas fini et
ne me répondez pas qu'au vu de
l'évolution démographique vous auriez pu
en supprimer bien davantage les
raisonnements comptables n'ont pas leur
place lorsque le système éducatif de
notre pays s'enfonce dans la médiocrité
l'enseignement n'est pas une dépense
indue c'est un investissement d'avenir
50 % des élèves
ant en 6e lisent péniblement avec leurs
doigts ce qui fait qu'ils sont capable
de suivre les enseignements du
collège s'il devait y avoir des maîtres
en surnombre vous disposeriez de
davantage de remplaçant vous pourriez
favoriser la co-intervention vous
pourriez faire de la qualité madame la
ministre et vos suppressions détruisent
un peu plus le tissu éducatif dont notre
pays a un besoin vital les peu regrettés
ellisabeth born et papend avaient promis
en 22 que la carte scolaire en milieu
rural serait établie sur une durée de 3
années et en étroite concertation avec
les municipalités que reste-t-il de cet
Ren bien entendu l'école madame la
ministre est en état d'urgence nous vous
demandons donc de prononcer un moratoire
sur ces fermetures et d'ouvrir enfin le
chantier main fois repoussé de
l'organisation de l'école primaire en
milieu rural nous demandons une
conférence nationale sur l'école rurale
je vousci merci beaucoup mon ch collègue
la parole est à Madame
amélieter ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
mes chers cègues je vous demande de
faireesser le
brou et et d' d'écouter la ministre s'il
vous plaît un peu de silence merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
chudo pour l'école de la République
aucun territoire ne doit être négligé ni
oublié bien entendu nous avons
aujourd'hui en France le maillage
territorial le plus fin en terme de
nombre d'écoles à l'échelle de notre
pays et le système d'allocation des
moyens est basé sur la prise en compte
de différents critères le les volumes
d'effectifs les dynamiques
démographiques ice de position sociale
des établissements et l'indice
d'éloignement nous avons grâce à toute
la politique menée depuis 2017 sur
l'école primaire considérablement
renforcer dans le premier degré les
ratios d'encadrement et baisser le
nombre d'écoles par classe de nombre
d'élèves par classe de manière
extrêmement significative et je veux
insister puisque votre question porte
spécifiquement sur la ruralité sur la
dynamique que nous avons engagé en la
matière les écoles rurales représentent
34 % des écoles publiques pour 18 % des
élèves elle présente donc un taux
d'encadrement qui est favorable les
engagements que vous avez mentionné
issus du plan France ruralité je
m'engage à les mettre en œuvre
pleinement oui cette visibilité sur 3
ans au niveau de la carte scolaire oui
ces instance de concertation et de
dialogue et oui aussi des initiatives
innovantes je pense notamment au
territoires éducatifs ruraux nous en
avions 91 il y a quelques mois nous
sommes maintenant à 190 et qui
permettent dans la même logique que
celle du CNR de promouvoir en local en
proximité des initiatives innovantes
pour préserver l'égalité des chances
dans tous nos territoires cet engagement
je l'ai dit je le respecterai sur toutes
ses dimensions carte scolaire territoire
éducatifs ruraux et instan de
coordination de dialogue entre les élus
et les services de l'État pour la
réussite de tous les élèves de ce pays
je vous remercie merci beaucoup madame
la
ministre par est à Monsieur Antoine
Armand pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Bruno le
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique monsieur le ministre notre
pays fait face à un mur énergétique
d'ici 2050 et même d'ici 2030 comme le
président de la République l'a présenté
à Belfort nous devrons baisser comme
jamais notre consommation d'énergie et
dans le le même temps nous devrons
simultanément produire une quantité
inédite d'énergie bacarbone sobriété
énergie renouvelable et nucléaire il
s'agit d'un défi immense ce défi il ne
souffrira pas vraiment le droit à la
paresse intellectuelle il ne souffrira
pas les incohérences incorrigibles de
ceux pour qui l'urgence serait
écologique tous les jours mais qui
refuse tous les jours la première source
d'énergie barrecbone en France le
nucléaire
ce défi ne souffrira pas non plus les
postures les postures des Patriotes du
dimanche ceux qui défendre la France
nous disent-il sauf sauf quand il s'agit
d'installer des énergies renouvelables
qui réduisent la dépendance au gaz
russe ce mur c'est le défi industriel de
notre temps et nous nous réjouissons que
l'industrie retrouve que l'énergie
retrouve le giron du ministère de
l'industrie comme nous l'avions
recommandé dans la commission d'enquête
que j'ai mené à avec mon collègue
Raphaël chellonberger nous aurons besoin
de panneaux solaires nous aurons besoin
d'éolienne nous aurons besoin de
centrale et d'infrastructure énergétique
en Europe pour que la transition soit
aussi la réindustrialisation que vous
avez lancé monsieur le ministre que vous
poursuivez depuis 2017 contevand et Maré
en baissant les impôts en simplifiant
notre droit en créant des emplois sur
notre territoire aussi Monsieur le
Ministre pouvez-vous préciser le
calendrier et les modalités de la
stratégie énergétique que vous comptez
poursuivre pour notre pays je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et
numérique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Antoine Armand le
défi français il est simple c'est
produire plus d'électricité décarbonée
dans les années qui viennent c'est un
défi considérrable parce que de ce défi
et notre capacité à le relever dépend
notre capacité à réindustrialiser le
pays à attirer de l'intelligence
artificielle à développer de nouveaux
secteurs économiques à développer
l'industrie automobile à développer
l'industrie aéronautique il faut doubler
la production d'électricité décarbonée
en France pour la passer de 27 % du mix
à plus de 50 % d'ici 2050 qu'est-ce que
ça suppose d'abord nous appuyer sur nos
atouts stratégiques et le premier nos
atouts stratégique vous l'avez
parfaitement dit ce sont les réacteurs
nucléaires nous avons engagé la
construction de six nouveaux pr avec une
première livraison d'ici 2035 et
d'autres pourrai suivre si les besoins
étaient justifiés deuxème chose c'est
accélérer le développement des énergies
renouvelables que ce soit le solaire
l'éolien l'éolien offshore ou l'éolien
onshore et bien entendu l'utilisation
des barrages qui mériteraiit d'être
mieux utilisé votre région le sait
parfaitement c'est un des enjeux majeurs
enfin le troème volet de notre stratégie
il a été rappelé très clairement par le
Président de la République dans son
discours de Belfort c'est économiser
l'énergie faire preuve de davantage de
sobriété faire preuve de davantage
d'efficacité récupérer l'énergie des
secteurs industriels pour pouvoir la
réutiliser sur le chauffage d'un certain
nombre de communes c'est avec cette
stratégie simple claire lisible
volontariste plus d'électricité plus de
nucléaire plus d'énergie renouvelable
plus de sobriété et plus d'efficacité
que la France occupera la place qui lui
revient la première économie décarbonée
en Europe à horizon
2040 merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Sabrina
SEBLi pour le groupe
écologiste monsieur le Premier ministre
nous revenons de Rafa à l'initiative de
notre collègue erriic cocrel vous le
savez c'est le seul point d'entrée de
l'aide humanitaire dans la bande de Gaza
nous avons pu y voir des kilomè de
camion interdit d'entrer par Israël avec
souvent un gâi considérable de denrée
cette amb ambulance seulement peuvent
passer par semaine pour évacuer les
blessés une ambulance par jour pour plus
de 66000 blessés et pour plus de 2
millions de Gazaoui n'ayant plus accès
aux soins qu'ils soi blessé malad ou
handicapés une ambulance par jour pour
l'unique hôpital encore en service de la
bande de Gaza où les personnels sur
place décrivent des conditions
effroyables le médecin français Raphaël
piti en opération à Gaza jusqu'hier
n'avait jamais vu de tes conditions de
tel massacre de civil dans aucun conflit
armé alors que l'enfan cile israélienne
a été reconnu comme représentant un
sérieux risque génocidaire par la Cour
internationale de Justice quel est le
devoir de la France est-il du devoir de
la France de poser fierèrement comme l'a
fait votre Ministre hier avec un
dirigeant d'extrême droite responsable
de plus de 27000 morts dont plus de 5000
enfants en lui demandant simplement le
respect des frontières de 67 est-il du
devoir de la France de ne pas condamner
l'offensive aveugle et démesuré
israélienne ayant rasé
0 % des infrastructures civiles d'un des
territoires les plus densément peuplés
au monde est-il de devoir de la France
de remettre en cause le financement de
l'agence des Nations Unies l'unra seul
capable aujourd'hui de secourir la
population civile dans l'enclave alors
même que plusieurs de nos pays voisins
comme l'Espagne ou l'Irlande ont
augmenté leur soutien monsieur le
Premier ministre le devoir de la France
est d'ê du côté de la dignité de
l'humanité c'est d'être du côté des
opprimés de poursuivre l'héritage
international chirakien celui qui nous
disait tant que les Palestiniens devront
s'accommoder d'une existence au Rabé les
frustrations et l'amertume l'emporteront
devoir de la France c'est la demande
d'un cesser le feu immédiat et permanent
dans une enclave onue à H clos le devoir
de la France c'est de refuser toutes les
colonisations car il n'est pas plus
grand comme droit que celui de pouvoir
jouir et vivre sur ses propres terres
Monsieur le Premier Ministre soyez à la
hauteur de notre
histoire merci la parole est à
madameis porte-parole du gouvernement
ministre chargé du renouveau
démocratique
merciameés madame la députée je vous
prie d'excuser le ministre des Affaires
étrangères Stéphane séjourné qui va
actuellement au Liban pour la dernière
étape de sa tournée diplomatique dans la
région après sêtre rendu en Égypte en
Jordanie en Israël et dans les
Territoires palestiniens les messages et
les objectifs du déplacement du ministre
sont clairs rappelez les devoirs de la
France condamnation sans ambiguïé des
actes terroristes du Hamas et demande de
libération immédiate de l'ensemble des
otages durable pour que cesse
effectivement l'enjeu humanitaire sur
place avec sur le volet humanitaire
consolider et accroître l'aide y compris
médicale sur le volet politique notre
objectif est constant et à rappeler
œuvrer vers une sortie de crise avec une
solution politique à deux états la
France est prête à poursuivre ses
efforts humanitaires notre contribution
à la plateforme de soutien présente en
en Égypte a permis notamment l'envoi de
1000 tonnes de fretes largué à Gaza
grâce à une coopération efficace les
habitants de Gaza et d'Israël doivent
pouvoir vivre en paix côte à côte vous
l'aurez compris madames les députés la
France s'engage à continuer et
continuera à s'engager pour un cesser le
feu sans
délai je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole pour le groupe la
France insoumise est à monsieur Éric
cocrel
mer monsieur le ministre nous nous
sommes rendus ce dimanche à Rafa avec
plusieurs parlementaires nous avons été
porté un message de paix le cessfeu
permanent et immédiat ass sorti de la
libération des otages nous y avons
rencontré les six médecins humanitaires
français sorti de Gaza ce lundi je vais
me donner ma voix à l'un deeux Raphaël
piti il parle de rue et de trottoir sans
1 m carré de libre parce que 2 millions
de personnes qui ont fui le nord de Gaza
bombardé puis le sud de Gaza bombardé à
son tour sont désormais massés sans
aucun abri dans un espace prévu pour en
accueillir 200000 il décrit leur hôpital
le sol à peu près intact comme un chaos
sanitaire un tiers des patients sont des
victimes des bombardements et des
snipers israéliens il le certifie il n'a
vu parmi eux que des civils ceux qui
arrivent là sont une minorité capable de
se traîner jusqu'à là les autres meurt
dans la rue le reste sont des
pathologies infections qui fautent de
médicament deviennent mortels Raphaël
piti a été main de fois en syrié en
Ukraine a été médecin militaire il n'a
jamais vu pareil désastr il dit aussi il
y a pire que tuer un homme c'est lui
enlever sa dignité ici il dit il y a que
27000 morts il y a 27000 morts et 2
millions d'êtres humains privés de leur
dignité quand on demande que pensez-vous
du risque génocidaire énoncé par la Cour
de justice internationale les six
répondent en même temps le génocide est
en cours dans un mois l'interrogation ne
sera de toute façon plus de mise car
l'unra la seule institution humanitaire
administrative présente pourrait
s'arrêter faute de financement pour
Raphaël piti si l'uner s'arrête la
population est condamnée monsieur le
ministre votre position pour in cesser
le feu a été apprécié en Égypte et par
les représentants palestiniens mais sur
cette question vitale la France doit
faire plus la France n'a pas suspendu
son aide mais pouvez-vous nous affirmer
qu'elle s'engagera à poursuivre les
versements à l'unra au moins jusqu'au
rendu du groupe d'évaluation de sa
neutralité créé par l'ONU et mené par
Catherine Colona que compte-elle faire
pour que les pays qui ont interrompu
leur verersement les États-Unis mais
aussi les autres pays européens
reviennent sur cette
décision
merci la parole est à Madame priscat
porte-parole du
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député coqurel je vais pas
reprendre tous les éléments que j'ai pu
fournir à votre collègue la députée CBA
simplement vous répondre sur l'unra si
vous le voulez bien et vous transmettre
la réponse du ministre des Affaires
étrangères qui est encore en tournée
diplomatique dans la zone au vu de la
situation humanitaire catastrophique à
Gaza la France poursuit la programmation
de ses soutiens aux agences des Nations
Unies qui ne prévoyit aucun versement à
l'unra au premier trimestre 2024 nous
attendons les conclusions du rapport
dans la rédaction a été confié à
Catherine Colona par le Secrétaire
général des Nations
unies je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
jeanvictor castor pour le groupe gauche
démocrate
républicaine madame la Présidente
monieurs les ministres ma question
s'adresse au Premier ministre monsieur
le Premier ministre
respecterez-vous le vote unanime des
élus de Guyane du 26 mars 2022 pour
avoir un article propre dans la
Constitution comme vous l'avez confirmé
pour les Corses le 24 janvier dernier le
congrès des élus réunit tous les maires
tous les élus territoriaux tous les
parlementaires et tous les présidents de
PCI je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
armanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outrem merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député comme vous l'avez
vous-même dit la Guyane qui réfléchit à
son avenir institutionnel je sais que le
président de la collectivité et
vous-même ainsi que les élus guyanais
l'ont déjà évoqué au président de la
République réfléchi en effet lorsqu'on
modifiera la Constitution et vous savez
que le Président de la République a
ouvert cette voie indépendamment de la
question calédonienne sur l'ensemble des
territoires ultrarin en effet à
accompagné des évolutions
institutionnelles souhaité si vous me le
permettez Monsieur le Député pas
simplement par les élus et nous avons
pris acte évidemment du vote de la
collectivité territoriale mais également
de la population il faut donc que nous
travaillons ensemble d'abord à la
précision d'un certain nombre de sujets
vous qui le savez très bien notamment
sur la doménialité en Guyane sur les
compétences et connaître en effet la
façon dont le conseil territorial va
consulter les électeurs guyanais nous
avons vu dans d'autres territoire
ultramarin des volontés par les élus qui
nétaient pas toujours suivis par les
habitants les populations intéressées
dit la Constitution mais oui nous sommes
ouverts en effet à la demande faite par
le territoire guyanais comme l'a précisé
le président de la République qui aura
très bientôt l'occasion de se rendre
vous le savez dans la belle terre de
Guyane je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur
castor le 21 avril 2017 plus de 40000
personnes étaient dans les rues de guyan
les accords de Guyane ont entériné
l'ouverture d'un nouveau processus
dévolution statutaire le 19 octobre 2022
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur vous
avez vous-même initié les rencontres
avec la Guyane sur un processus de
discussion similaire à celui de la Corse
qui devait aboutir en septembre 2023
malgré toutes les relances le
gouvernement est resté sourd durant plus
d'un an comprenez que la nomination
aujourd'hui de deux experts est pour le
cas de la Guyane de l'enfumage qui
consiste à ignorer un processus engagé
depuis le premier ministre Édouard
Philippe sur un territoire aussi grand
doté d'un potentiel humain
extraordinaire et qui regorge de
ressources par sa biodiversité et par
son sous-sol or diamant pétrole gaz
boxite Colin tentalite terre rare il est
inadmissible que 53 % de la population
viv sous le seuil de
pauvreté la situation chaotique guanaise
est la conséquence d'empilement de
normes et de décisions politiques
parisiennes inadapté et le plus souvent
absurde est-ce normal que le commerce
avec nos voisins immédiats soit entravé
à l'heure de la sobriété énergétique
est-ce normal que des agriculteurs
renoncent à s'installer faute de terre
exploitable sur un territoire de 8400000
hectares le constat est implacable le
statutco n'est plus possible il est
évident que la Guyane doit changer de
cadre statutaire elle en a toutes les
ressources nécessaires merci merci
monsieur le député monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le député je regrette que
vous n'ayez pas écouté la réponse que je
viens de vous faire en vous disant que
nous étions favoraablees à la dévolution
statutaire mais vous ne vous êtes pas
engagé monsieur le député vous ne vous
êtes pas engagé sur la consultation de
la population guyanaise comme en Corse
comme en nouvelle céonie il faut
consulter les habitants et les électeurs
et les manifestations ne font pas les
élections dans le projet porté par la
collectivité je rappelle je le dis à
l'Assemblée nationale vous souhaitez une
citoyenneté guyanaise et un corps
électoral restreint je pense que ça
demande aux électeurs guyanais le soin
de pouvoir voter pour son propre avenir
vous vous êtes pas engagé sur consulter
les Guyanais le gouvernement vous
demande de consulter les Guyanais sur
votre projet je vous remercie monsieur
le
ministre la prochaine question va être
posée par par Monsieur Frédéric sgansski
pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
démocrate madame merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Premier Ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Marc fenau ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire vous avez pris une décision
difficile mais nécessaire concernant la
suspension du plan écofito la semaine
dernière évidemment la réduction de
l'utilisation de produit phytosanitaire
doit rester une priorité cependant il
est également impératif d'accompagner
nos agriculteurs dans cette voie il est
impensable de les laisser sans solution
tant qu'en traitement alternatif ne sera
pas disponible la transition vers une
agriculture plus durable et plus
respectueuse de l'environnement passe
par une modification en profondeur des
pratiques agricoles mais cela nécessite
un vrai soutien à l'innovation pour
trouver des alternatives aux produits de
synthèse je pense en particulier aux
solutions de biocontrôle qui font appel
à des mécanismes naturel ces
alternatives aux pesticides sont à la
fois efficaces et respectueuses de la
santé des sols des écosystèmes et des
populations or il est urgent de soutenir
financièrement cette filière 10 millions
d'euros par an sont d'ors et déjà prévus
pour des projets de recherche et de
déploiement il faut amplifier cet effort
pour que la Red et les expérimentations
s'accélèrent et que des solutions
alternatifes soit trouvé pour tous les
usages en parallèle il est nécessaire
d'alléger les procédures d'homologation
particulièrement longues complexe et
parfois décourageante pour nos jeunes
entreprises françaises qui se lancent
dans le biocontrôle nous avons la chance
d'avoir des sociétés françaises leader
en matière d'innovation dans le domaine
de biosolution et du biocontrôle je
pense notamment à immun rise biocontrôle
présente dans ma commune de Cestas il
est impératif de les soutenir pour
conserver notre avance et travailler
ainsi à la reconquête de notre
souveraineté alimentaire ainsi Monsieur
le Ministre pouvez-vous nous dire quels
sont les leviers que le gouvernement
compte activer pour favoriser le
développement de solutions alternatives
française et ainsi accompagner les
agriculteurs vers la transition
écologique tout en maintenant leur
compétitivité je vous remercie je vous
merci la parole est à Monsieur Marc F
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
député monsieur le
députéansski deux éléments de réponse le
premier sur le plan écofito on a décidé
effectivement de le mettre en posuse
pour quelques semaines le temps de
d'analyser deux choses la première c'est
la question des
indicateurs nous avons besoin d'un
indicateur qui reflète bien les efforts
qui sont faits par l'agriculture et qui
ne soit pas un processus de
découragement de ceux qui essaient de
trouver des alternatives ou de sortir
des produits qui sont les plus à risque
puis deuxième élément des mesures de
simplification pour éviter les
surtranspositions je pense en
particulier au registre numérique et
s'inspirant d'ailleurs de des travaux
qui ont été menés par le député
propotier le député descroosaille dans
le cadre de leur commission d'enquête
sur pourquoi écofito ne va pas aussi
loin qu'on l'espérait à l'époque en 2009
2è élément 2è élément les alternatives
parce que c'est ça sur lequel il faut
travailler il y a différents types
d'alternatives avec des produits phyo ou
avec des sououtils de biocontrôle ou de
bio stimulant vous dire que nous avons
travaillé il y a déjà un programme vous
l'avez évoqué qui est en cours sur ces
sujets là on a deux sujets le premier
c'est que l'innovation doit pouvoir
s'accompagner d'une rapidité sur les
homologations donc on a besoin
d'accélérer le fait queun fois qu'on a
trouvé une innovation plus se déployer
soit en expériimentation soit en
généralisation et là aussi il faut
travailler au niveau national et au
niveau européen pour que dès lors qu'on
a trouvé une alternative on puisse très
rapidement la mettre à disposition des
agriculteurs c'est un élément évidemment
central cette innovation doit pouvoir
aller comme on dit dans les cours de
ferme et puis le deuxième sujet c'est
les moyens qu'on doit y consacrer je
lancerai dans quelques semaines ou
quelques jours avec ma collègue Sylvie
retaillot un programme dans le cadre de
France 2030 qui vise à à encourager les
biostimulants et les outils du
biocontrôle doté de 60 millions d'euros
donc 42 millions d'euros de fonds
publics il y aura 18 millions de fonds
privés parce qu'on a besoin que les
firmes puissent rentrer dans la logique
pour accompagner et les solutions dont
ont besoin les agriculteurs la
transition ça doit pas être une punition
la transition ça doit être des moyens
des objectifs et de l'accompagnement et
c'est ce qu'on met sur la table sur ces
sujets
là merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Fabrice BR pour le groupe les
républicaain merci merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Premier Ministre
les tracteurs sont tout juste rentrés
dans les fermes de France et déjà les
déclarations contradictoires des membres
de votre gouvernement fusent dans le
plus grand désordre si vous pensez avoir
berné les agriculteurs ou avoir acheté
leur silence vous faites là une grave
erreur soyez conscient que sans
traduction de vos paroles en acte d'ici
le salon d'agriculture le retour de
manivelle sera terrible terrible pour
notre agriculture et notre alimentation
terrible pour notre économie qui ne
résisterait pas à l'agglomération de
toutes les colères après 7 ans de Fr
facturation macroniste oui les
agriculteurs veulent vivre dignement de
leur métier plus de rémunération moins
de charg moins de normes avec un cap
clair pas d'interdiction sans solution
stop à la surtransposition à la
française arrêtez d'emmerder les
agriculteurs et les éleveurs
français contrôle plutôt les rayons et
les containers on n peut plus de cette
concurrence déloyale de ces produits qui
ne respecte pas les mêmes normes que
nous juste échange réciprocité des
normes exonération de charg sur la
mainœuvre saisonnière et permanente choc
de
simplification réparation de l'injustice
des retraites agricoles prédation GNR
écopyo application stricte de la loi
égalim les solutions existent c'est
d'abord et toujours avant tout une
question de volonté politique comme pour
l'eau qu'il faut stocker l'hiver pour
utiliser l'été partout où c'est possible
et pas au cas par cas selon le bon
vouloir de votre
administration c'est du bon sens paysan
comme les 60 propositions de notre livre
blanc alors Monsieur le Premier Ministre
serez-vous au rendez-vous des promesses
tenues au salon de l'agriculture vous
êtes attendu au
tournant je vous remercie mon chers
collègu la parole est à Monsieur Mar
ministre de
l'Agriculture merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député brun
vous avez fait la liste des sujets que
nous avons mis nous-mêmes sur la table
et ne croyez
[Applaudissements]
pas ne croyez pas que nous considérions
ni le Premier ministre ni le président
de la République ni les membres du
gouvernement que nous ayons fini avec
cette crise il y a des réponses qui ont
été apportées dans dans l'immédiaté des
réponses pour répondre à les crises je
pense au Chris bovin des réponses qui
ont été apportées sur la crise viticole
et vous avez raison les agriculteurs ils
nous attendent dans la durée ils nous
attendent avant le salon sur un certain
nombre de chos je vais y revenir juste
après et pardon de vous dire ils nous
attendent après le salon parce que 20 ou
30 ans de difficultés qui ont été posées
sur la table il faut dès à présent faire
ce que nous pouvons faire et s'inscrire
dans la durée et dès avant le salon et
dans le temps qui nous amène au salon on
va d'abord travailler sur les mesures de
simplification nous avons dès à présent
un certain nombre de mesures qui ont été
posé qui ont été posées et indiqué par
le Premier ministre sur les délais de
recours sur les procédures qui sont trop
lourdes et puis nous faisons un travail
avec les organisations profess
départemental avec sous lesgit des
préfets pour regarder tout le champ de
simplification qu'on doit ouvrir et
croyez-moi la sédimentation depuis des
dizaines d'années est très grande et
donc on va avancer comme ça et puis on
va avancer sur les autres sujets je
pense au sujet européens on a besoin de
continuer j'ai entendu ce qu'a dit la
présidente van derlyen sur la nécessité
de réouvrir le champ du dialogue et le
champ de la coopération au niveau
européen pour faire en sorte que la
politique agricole elle permette à la
fois la transition mais de s'assurer de
la souveraineté agricole c'est ça sur
lequel on a on a besoin de travailler
ensemble donc on a des mesures de court
terme des mesures autour de
l'installation ça sera traduit autour du
projet de loi d'orientation et d'avenir
agricole qui sera présenté avec un
calendrier qui permett un calendrier qui
permettra d'ici le mois de juin que les
deux lectures puissent être faites à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat c'est
ça le calendrier je suis sûr que vous
apporterez votre contribution pour à la
fois engager la transition mais engager
aussi la volonté de souveraineté que
nous partageons je le crois merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Arthur de la
porte pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier ministre vous avez
promis d'apporter la cause de l'école à
Matignon mais de quelle école
parlez-vous celle de l'école publique
gratuite laïque et obligatoire ou celle
de l'école payante réservée à une caste
et beau quartier celle de la mixité
sociale ou celle de la ségrégation
scolaire celle de la laïcité qui
s'impose ou celle des cours religieux
imposés celle de l'égalité entre les
sexes ou celle des classes pour les
filles et les classes pour les garçons
cell de l'éducation civique et de
l'éducation à la vie sexuelle ou cell
qui prent des discours sexistes et des
discours homophobes celle de
l'émancipation des élèves
de l'uniforme obligatoire celle de
l'éducation populaire ou celle du
service national universel
d'endoctrinement de la jeunesse celle du
libre choix de son orientation ou celle
de parcours sup
contourné celle d'un enseignant devant
chaque classe ou celle à laquelle on
supprime 6500 postes depuis
2017 Monsieur le Premier Ministre la
colère gronde dans le Finistère en is
dans le PU dans le calad des classes des
écoles fermes les dotations horaires
enène Saint- aussi sont réduites à pot
de chacrin partout en France les
revendications sont les mêmes
aujourd'hui comme jeudi dernier des
dizaines de milliers d'enseignants sont
dans la rue ESC en cœur Amélie oua
Castera démission Amélie oua ctera
démission Monsieur le Premier Ministre
écoutezles pour une
fois parole est à Madame Amélie oua
casterin ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des Sports
Monsieur le monsieur le député de la
porte opposer l'école publique à l'école
privée c'est vraiment une guerre d'un
autre âge et qu'il est juste hors de
question de raviver depuis la loi de Bré
de 59 sous la présidence du général de
Gaulle les unes cohabitent avec les
autres liberté de l'enseignement et
qualité du service public
de l'éducation 50 % des familles ont
fait le choix à un moment ou à un autre
de mettre au moins un de leurs enfants
dans l'école privé mais ce que je vous
je veux vous exprimer c'est la volonté
qui est la nôtre illustrée par la
mobilisation de 60 effectifs
d'inspection supplémentairire pour nous
assurer que l'école privée est au
rendez-vous de ces obligations en
matière pédagogique en matière
financière en matière administrative sur
le plan des du respect des valeurs de la
République et tout particulièrement de
la laïcité mais aussi monsieur le député
en matière de mixité sociale et scolaire
où le secrétariat général de
l'enseignement catholique a pris des
engagements vis-à-vis de nous dont nous
nous assurons de la bonne mise en œuvre
ça veut dire un meilleur suivi sur les
conditions d'accès aux établissements
privés ça veut dire plus de transparence
sur ces conditions d'accès ça veut dire
une amélioration du taux de boursier
c'est tout ce dispositif là dont nous
nous voulons nous assurer de l'effective
mise en œuvre parce que nous voulons
faire réussir toutes les écoles de ce
pays donc ce protocole qui date de mai
2023 assorti de moyens spécifiques nous
ferons en sorte qu'il y ait le bon
niveau d'exigence l'école privée mérite
des moyens ni plus ni moins que la juste
allocation que le niveau d'élèves qui
sont scolarisés à savoir 17 % dans notre
pays avec une prise en compte de
l'indice de position sociale des
établissements requier faire réussir
tous les élèves de notre pays toutes les
écoles de notre pays merci beaucoup
madame la ministre monsieur de la
porte madame la ministre la guerre
scolaire c'est vous qui la ravivez ce
n'est pas nous c'est vous qui employez
ces termes c'est vous qui refusez de
vous expliquer c'est vous qui refusez de
démissionner c'est vous qui n'assumez m
c'est vous qui insultez les enseignants
c'est votre bilan c'est celui de votre
gouvernement maintenant écoutez les
enseignants
merci la parole est à Monsieur gu bricou
pour le groupe Liot merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de l'Éducation
nationale élu du craisil dominante rural
j'ai assisté à de nombreuses cérémonies
de vœux les maires me font part de
beaucoup de difficultés à gérer leur
communes mais dans presque toutes les
communes la fermeture les Mair j'ai
entendu les maires vouloir rénover ou
construire une école projeter leur
commune dans la IR or nous venons
d'apprendre dans l'ensemble du pays la
fermeture de nombreuses classes 29 dans
ma circonscription qui s'ajoute à celle
de l'année dernière réduire à une seule
classe une école dans un village c'est
condamner à terme l'école l'école c'est
la vie du territoire c'est le lien
indéfectible de la nation avec ses
enfants or notre classement au plan
mondial ne fait que
dégringoler certes nous ne pouvons nier
une des cru démographique mais elle
existe depuis 2017 hors de 2017 à 2022
les classes ont été maintenues grâce
c'est le terme utilisé à des
dispositifs pourquoi brusquement à
partir de 2022 fermer drastiquement les
classes au contraire nous estimons que
cette situation doit être l'opportunité
de diminuer le nombre d'élèves par
classe d'autant plus que les
dédoublements et le plafonnement des
classes ont fait leur preuve votre choix
a-t-il été de supprimer des postes dans
le 1ier le second degré un choix auquel
nous nous sommes opposés au groupe lotte
lors des deux derniers budgets notamment
par un amendement de notre collègue
Béatrice Descamp avant que ne tombe le
493 nous ne pouvons nier qu'il y a une
concertation avec le daen et les IEN je
les en remercie mais ils ne font
qu'appliquer les instructions du
ministre dans un contexte de difficulté
économique et sociale vous avez
l'occasion de répondre à un réel enjeu
pour l'avenir de nos territoires aussi
comment comptez-vous mettre en place une
politique publique efficace contre les
fermetures de classe en général et
quelle réponse pouvez-vous apporter aux
parents et enfants touchés par de
nombreuses fermetures merci beaucoup mon
cher collègue la parole est à Madame
Amélie oua Castera ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des Sports Monsieur le Député bricou
merci pour votre question qui est en
effet extraordinairement important
d'avoir une carte scolaire qui réponde
véritablement aux besoins des
territoires qui prennent en compte les
indices d'éloignement les indices de
position sociale des établissements
l'évolution des effectifs les dynamiques
démographiques c'est tout ceci que nos
équipes sur le terrain veillent vous
l'avez dit en concertation avec les élus
à mettre en place moi je veux revenir
sur l'évolution des taux d'encadrement
compte tenu de la politique que nous
avons mené en matière de dédoublement
des classes dans le primaire les ratios
d'encadrement se sont considérablement
améliorés et je ve vous donner également
ces réalités pour la ruralité à laquelle
je vous sa particulièrement attaché les
taux d'encadrement dans ce milieu rural
sont très favorables avec une moyenne de
19,4 élèves par classe dans les communes
rurales qui sont éloignées ce qui
s'améliore par rapport à 2020 et dans
les autres communes rurales ce taux il
est de 21,5 ce qui les positionne mieux
que le ratio national qui lui est de
22,7 simplement nous sommes à certain
moment obligés de procéder à certaines
fermetures de classes les peuvent être
performantes mais si le nombre d'enfants
est trop réduit pour une classe donnée
c'est toute l'émulation qui est remise
en cause et la capacité de progression
de nos enfants tous les professeurs vous
le diront nous portons une égale
ambition pour tous les territoires dans
les zones d'éducation prioritaire mais
aussi pour la ruralité où il y a cette
concertation que vous avez évoqué où il
y a cette volonté d'anticipation de la
carte scolaire sur une dynamique de 3
ans et où il y a la mise en place des
territoires éducatifs ruraux
0 à la rentrée prochaine qui nous Perm
de travailler avec tous les services de
l'État toutes les associations et les
élus pour proposer des solutions
adaptées innovantes constructives pour
les élèves notamment en ruralité je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à présent à
Monsieur th beno pour le groupe
horizon merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie
la mobilisation des agriculteurs a
continué de poser la question du revenu
agricole et plus particulièrement celui
des
éleveurs le gouvernement a lui-même
pointé le rôle des centrales d'achat
internationales hébergé à l'étranger
permettant ainsi à certaines
négociations commerciales d'échapper au
droit français quelle mesure monsieur le
ministre l'Union européenne peut-elle
mettre en œuvre pour que égalim
s'applique à la lettre en France mais
aussi en Europe 2è point dans le secteur
laitier les organisations de producteurs
sont en grande difficulté dans la
contractualisation avec certains
industriels c'est le cas de Lunel avec
l'entreprise Lactalis
ou le cas de sonley avec l'entreprise
savencia avec dans ce dernier cas la
crainte pour certains éleveurs laitiers
de ne plus être collecté au mars
aujourd'hui les pouvoirs publics sont
interpellés par les organisations de
producteurs monsieur le ministre quel
suite le Gouvernement entend-il donner à
l'alerte de certaines organisations de
producteurs je vous remercie je vous
remerci la parole est à Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire ministre de l'Économie des
Finances la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député thry benoî je connais
votre attachement au monde agricole en î
et Villain dans le canton de fougère et
plus loin et vous pouvez compter sur la
détermination totale du gouvernement du
premier ministre du ministre de
l'agriculture et de moi-même à faire
respecter l'ensemble des dispositions de
la loi égalim que les choses soient bien
clairire un produit qui est négocié et
qui est vendu en France respecte toutes
les dispositions de la loi égalim qui
est été négocié sur le territoire
français ou dans une centrale d'achat
européenne et j'ai demandé à la
direction générale la consommation la
répression des fraudes de veiller à ce
que tous les produits en particulier
laitiers qui ont été négociés par
l'intermédiaire de centrale d'achat
européenne respecte rigoureusement
l'ensemble des dispositions de la loi
égalim sur 1000 contrats nous en avons
124 qui ne respecte pas les dispositions
de la loi égalime j'ai envoyé les
injonctions au 124 industriels et
distributeurs concernés ils ont 15 jours
pour se conformer à la loi égalim faute
de quoi ils encour une sanction de 5
million d'euros par distributeur ou par
industriel notre main ne tremblera pas
nous serons intraitables avec ceux qui
ne respectent pas les disposition de la
loi
égali quant aux organisations de
producteurs nous les avons mis en place
ensemble monsieur le député nous avons
créé nous-même quand j'étais ministre de
l'Agriculture et vous-même députés ces
organisations de producteurs qui
permettent de négocier en position de
force le prix du lait entre les
producteurs de lait les industriels et
ensuite les distributeurs il n'est pas
acceptable et le Premier ministre l'a
rappelé dans sa conférence de presse il
y a quelques jours que des industriels
puissent négocier le prix de leurs
produits avec les distributeurs alors
même qu'ils n'ont pas conclu leurs
négociation avec les producteurs de lait
nous veillerons là aussi à ce que la loi
soit strictement respectée et à ce que
Galim soit renforcé sur ce point précis
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieuroît merci madame la Présidente
comme il reste quelques secondes je
voulais simplement dire que sur les
centrales d'achat hébergé dans d'autres
pays que la France l'Union européenne
devrait procéder au même travail qu'on a
réalisé ici il y a 5 ans une commission
d'enquête sur le fonctionnement des
cendrales d'achat qui sont hébergé à
l'international et notamment en Europe
sur les organisations de
producteurs l'objectif que vous aviez
fixé lorsque vous étiez ministre de
l'Agriculture c'était la
contractualisation moi je considère que
le groupe Lactalis et et l'entreprise
savencia sont de grands industriels qui
doivent vraiment donner l'exemple dans
le domaine du prix de façon à ce que
l'ensemble des industriels et l'ensemble
des éleveurs litiers soit rémunéré à la
hauteur des des travaux et des efforts
qu'il
fournissent je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe schre pour le rassemblement
national merci Madame merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Premier Ministre
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des autres
maires monsieur le ministre
permettez-moi de vous rappeler des
chiffres que vous connaissez car il
s'agit des chiffres communiqués la
semaine dernière par votre ministère en
2023 les homicides ont progressé de 5 %.
en 2023 les coupts et blessures
volontaires ont progressé de 7 % les
violences intrafamiliales de 9 % les
viols et tentatives de 10 %, les autres
agressions sexuel de 7 % les vols avec
armes de 2 % les cambriolages et
dégradations volontaires de 3 % les
trafics de stupéfiants de 4 % les
escroqueries de 7 % derrière ces
chiffres se trouvent des femmes et des
hommes broyés pénalisés financièrement
malheureux plus que des statistiques vos
chiffres sont des marqueurs du deuil de
la souffrance et de la peur la hausse de
la délinquence notamment violente et
constante quasiment à sens unique et
touche tous les territoires les chiffres
sont têtus et ceux qui considèrent que
la France n'est pas un coupegorge
refusent de voir la réalité que vivent
les Français monsieur le ministre à
l'approche des Jeux Olympiques avez-vous
conscience que l'insécurité n'est pas un
sentiment et quelles actions
entendez-vous mettre en œuvre pour
casser la courbe de la
délinquenceér je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur Géral Darmanin ministre
de l'Intérieur et des outres
mires merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député je partage bien
évidemment que l'insécurité n'est pas un
sentiment mais qu'il faut lutter contre
d'insécurité avec toute son énergie et
je regrette que vous n'avez pas eu un
mot pour les policiers les gendarmes qui
se bêent tous les jours sans doute que
ça ne vous arrange
pas sans doute que vous ne souhaitez pas
les les soutenir et moi je veux dire que
je suis fier d'être à leur tête depuis
bientôt 4 ans parce que je sais qu'il
faut un travail
quotidien s'il vous plaît je prends
l'exemple de votre département monsieur
le député dommage que vous n'ayez pas
cette vision locale de vos chiffres de
la délinquence et de vos policiers vous
auriez souligné qu'il y a 143 policiers
de plus depuis 2 ans dans votre
département et que dans le département
du Var c'est 28 % de vol de véhicule 6 %
de vol avec armes 11 % de vol violents
mais sans doute ce qui vous intéresse ce
sont les choses négatives il faut
évidemment les combattre mais vous
n'avez pas signé nationalement
l'intégralité des chiffres quand on dit
la vérité on na dit pas à moitié pour la
première fois % de violence dans les
transports de vol violents pour la
première fois la baisse dans les
cambriolages alors que depuis 15 ans ils
augmenté continuellement la vérité
monsieur le député c'est que vous êtes
heureux quand les Français vont
mal je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député allez-y
oui monsieur monsieur le ministre
manifestement votre gouvernement
continue à avoir quelques difficulté
avec les
mathématiques un anci ministre de
l'Agriculture n'avit aucune idée de ce
qui était un hectare et vous vous nous
expliquez que plus et plus ça fait moins
en fait plus et plus ça fait jamais
moins ça fait toujours plus et si depuis
que vous êtes au pouvoir les homicides
volontaires ont progressé depu 30 %
c'est pas qu'il a moins de mort c'est
qu'il y en a 180 de plus par an donc
merci pour les statistiques du Var mais
vous n'êtes pas le ministre du Var hein
vous êtes le ministre de l'ensemble du
pays et les Français malheureusement
chaque semaine chaque année sont de la
politique désastreuse que vous menez
avec l'elage que vous forz que vous
formez avec le garde des saau je vous
remercie je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député vos
électeurs du Var sont heureux que vous
fichez de votre département c'est un
premier
problème et c'est l'inconvénient
monsieur le député c'est l'inconvénient
d'écrire sa réponse avant d'entendre ma
réponse c'est que vous finissez par lire
les éléments de langage de Monsieur
monsieur Bardella au lieu de vous
concentrer sur la vérité pour les
Français je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Michel
lausan pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre dans ma
circonscription à agin depuis plusieurs
années lors de leur mobilisation j'ai eu
l'occasion d'échanger avec les
agriculteurs
des femmes et des hommes portant des
revendications légitimes et voulant
faire entendre leur mal-être et les
difficultés pesant sur leur profession
depuis plusieurs décennies accablé
d'abord par des normes et des
injonctions souvent contradictoires
éprouvé aussi car ils consacrent leur
vie ainsi que celle de leur famille à
leur métier sans pouvoir s'en sortir
dignement en colère enfin face à
certains discours politiques les
accusant à tort d'être responsable de
tous les dommages environnementaux ou
ceux qui les instrumentalisent à des
fins de récupération
politicienne pourtant ces mêmes
agriculteurs ont démontré qu'ils n'ont
pas perdu l'espoir l'espoir de vivre
dignement de leur travail et de nourrir
correctement nos concitoyens les
revendications étant multiples car les
agricultures et leurs besoins sont
parfois différents selon leur région et
les secteurs de production en ce sens je
salue l'éventail très concret et adapté
de vos annonces qui ont permis
d'apporter des réponses rapides et
claires pour l'agriculture il y aura un
avant et un après cette mobilisation
avec par exemple le grand chantier de la
simplification que nous devrons
dupliquer à tous les secteurs de
l'action publique le chemin est long
cette nouvelle démarche est nécessaire
et les agriculteurs restent mobilisés
attentifs aux résultats concrets aussi
Monsieur le Ministre pourriez-vous nous
indiquer quelles mesures concrètes vous
avez déjà prises et qu quels sont les
dossiers sur lesquels vous travaillez
d'ici au Salon de l'Agriculture pour
répondre aux besoins de nos agriculteurs
et soutenir notre souveraineté et notre
modèle agricole français je vous
remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Marc
fen ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député lausan merci
de votre
question les agriculteurs au fond et
finalement ils ont posé sur la table une
question existentielle c'est la capacité
à continuer à pouvoir vivre de leur
travail et le deuxième sujet c'est la
question du rapport à la société c'est
au fond qu'est-ce que la société attend
de nous et parfois vous l'avez dit les
discours qui ont été ceux de la
stigmatisation ont fait beaucoup de mal
à l'agriculture et aux agriculteurs
alors nous avons répondu dans l'urgence
avec le Premier ministre et les autres
collègues ministres sur plusieurs sujets
d'abord sur les les secteurs qui étaient
en crise je pense au secteur des
beauvins je pense au secteur de la
viticulture je pense au secteur du bio
des fonds d'urgence qui sont déployés
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux dès à
présent qui qui vont permettre de
soulager les trésoreries et de faire
face aux situations les plus périlleuses
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux
deuxième élément toujours sur les bvins
bvin pardon la la réponse à la question
de la maladie hémorragique épisotique
qui est un un formidable défi un
terrible défi pour le pour cette filière
et que nous allons accompagné par la
prise en charge des frais vétérinaires
et des pertes d'animaux sur la question
viticole on a besoin aussi de travailler
sur des questions plus structurelles et
c'est le travail que nous faisons avec
la filière et que nous avions commencé
il y a plusieurs semaines et plusieurs
mois pour faire en sorte que par la
restructuration du vgum nous puissions
mieux répondre au besoins et à la
demande et répondre au défi lui aussi
formidable et important de la
surproduction vticol que nous avons
aujourd'hui sous les yeux c'est ça et la
vérité donc c'est les mesures
structurelles et puis des mesures de
simplification le Premier ministre les a
annoncé des mesures de simplification
autour des procédures je pense à
l'élevage et à l'eau sur lesqueles avec
le notre mon collègue Christophe béchou
on a travaillé très rapidement dès la
semaine dernière enfin il y a une
dizaine de jours déjà pour regarder tout
ce qu'on pouvait faire pour accélérer
les processur les processus simplifier
les processusus et les rendre plus
lésibles pour les agriculteurs et puis
nous avons un travail de moyen et long
terme poursuivre la simplification
travailler au niveau de l'Union
européenne on a besoin d'interroger la
PAC dans son fondement de souveraineté
transition et c'est bien ça la question
qui est posée à la fois par les
agriculteurs français les agriculteurs
européens c'est le travail que nous
avons encore amener devant nous la
simplification la transition et la
compétitivité merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Marianne
maximi pour le groupe la France
insoumise
merci madame la
Présidente c'était une enfant elle avait
15 ans elle s'appelait Lili la semaine
dernière elle s'est donné la mort dans
sa chambre d'hôtel où elle a été placée
par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance je voudrais que notre
assemblée lui rende hommage et apporte
son soutien à ses proches aux éducateurs
qui font du mieux qu'ils peuvent dans un
contexte d'effondrement de la protection
de
l'enfance
madame la
ministre que faisait une enfant de 15
ans seule dans un hôtel ne me répondez
pas que c'était un hôtel pas un hôtel
mais un centre d'hébergement pour
mineurs même conventionné avec les
départements les hôtels restent des
hôtels des lieux inadaptés pour les
enfants notamment les plus
vulnérables l'état connaissait la
dangerosité de ce type de placement
Anthony Jess Nour tous sont morts dans
ce type d'hébergement en 19 l'Inspection
générale des affaires sociales a alerté
sur les dangers bien identifiés dont
l'isolement et l'exposition au trafic et
la prostitution en 2022 notre Assemblée
a voté pour pour interdire les
placements en hôtel qu'il ne soit plus
possible sans accompagnement éducatif
renforcé que s'est-il passé depuis rien
le décret d'application n'est jamais
paru une dizaine d'autres d'ailleurs non
plus la loi 2022 est l'une des lois les
moins appliquées de tout le premier
quinquena d'Emmanuel Macron cette
nonapplication dit beaucoup du mépris
social qui entoure le devenir des
enfants placés pourtant ces enfants ont
des droits l'État lui-même a envers eux
des devoirs quand tu casses tu répares
nous dit le Premier ministre mais qui va
réparer la protection de l'enfance que
le gouvernement laisseeffondrer qui va
réparer les familles qui n'ont pas
trouvé d'aide quand il en avait besoin
qui va réparer les VI enfants brisés par
des parcours chaotiques en protection de
l'enfance qui va réparer des
professionnels en souffrance et à bout
face à une protection de l'enfance en
ruine il nous faut commencer dès
maintenant à prendre des mesures fortes
madame la ministre quand comptez-vous
interdire les placements en hôtel pas
les aménager ni les encadrer les
interdire merci
beaucoup la parole est à madameis
porte-parole du
gouvernement merci madame la présidente
madame la députée Maxim au nom
gouvernement c'est moi à mon tour
d'apporter tout mon soutien aux proches
de Lili mais également aux
professionnels touchés par cette
disparition
tragique une cellule psychologique a été
mise en place pour apporter tout le
soutien nécessaire à l'équipe éducative
dévoué ainsi qu'aux autres jeunes de
l'établissement une enquête est en cours
et permettra de faire toute la lumière
sur ce drame
absolu je vous réponds au nom de la
ministre du Travail de la de la santé et
de de la solidarité qui est actuellement
au Sénat la loi taaquée du 7 février
2022 qui a fait suite à un travail
approfondi de plusieurs mois avec tous
les professionnels concernés et les
départements de France et les
parlementaires a permis que la parole de
l'enfant soit davantage prise en compte
et mieux prise en compte cette loi qui
est mise en œuvre oui un certain nombre
de décrets d'application été déjà
publiés mais d'autres étaient en attente
et donc je vous annonce aujourd'hui que
le décret précisant les conditions
d'interdiction de la prise en charge hô
vient d'être signé par le Premier
ministre le gouvernement souhaite
poursuivre le dialogue avec le les
départements sur les conditions de mise
en œuvre de la loi taqué pour toujours
mieux protéger les jeunes de laaz nous
le devons à tous ces enfant qui n'aspire
qu'à une chose vivre comme tous les
autres
merci je vous remercie madame la
[Musique]
ministre la parole est à monsieur me
pour le groupe les
républicains
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Ministre 4 mois après lesprome
du 7 octobre la Fran rend demain un
hommage national à ses 42 enfants
massacrés par les djihadistes du Hamas
enfin avidane Valentin Karine Ruth Naomi
Sigal Céline Elia et les autres 42
français parmi les 1200 civils massacrés
des capité brûlé ces femmes violées puis
tué devant leur famille leur corps
profané et exhibé comme des trophées
je regrette par ailleurs que les
familles des dizaines de soldats
franco-israéliens tombés en héros ne soi
pas conviés à cet hommage mais je pense
surtout au36 otages détenus en ce moment
dans les G djihadistes au béb Kfir 1 an
et à toutes ces femmes violé en
permanence mais comme je le craignais
après la compassion la sidération vient
le temps des accusations de l'inversion
de la charge et même de la nazification
d'Israël au Grand Cirque de la haie
l'Afrique du Sud régime corrompu
criminogène place l'État juif sur le
banc des accus dans un simulacre de
prosé qui déshonore la justice
internationale le monde doit comprendre
80 ans après la Choa que le peuple juif
n'ira plus jamais à l'abattoir sans
réagir cette guerre a été imposée à
Israël c'est un acte de justice et non
de vengeance pendant ce temps l'extrême
gauche est Arafa pas un mot pour les
otages elle vient pour soutenir l'agence
de l'ONU impliqué directement dans les
porô et donct il faut définitivement
cesser le financement comble de
l'indécence et de la provocation ils
seront là de demain qui imagine Bousquet
Papon Fisson participer à l'hommage
annuel de la rafle du veldive car c'est
cela dont il s'agit monsieur le Premier
ministre je suis le député de ses
familles qui ont écrit au Président de
la République elle ne veut pas des
pores-parol des porte-paroles du ramas
demain la France ne peut balayer leurs
émotion et leur colère oui l'indignité
existe elle rôe près de Marianne et il
dépose ses tumeurs de grâce qu'ils a un
sursaut de décence et d'humanité envers
les victimes pour ne pas s'imposer à à
l'hommage pas aux Invalides républicain
Monsieur le Premier Ministre pourquoi
les avoir invité pourquoi ne pas dresser
comme par le passé pour d'autres un
cordon sanitaire avec les antisémites
qui font l'apologie du terrorisme et
disIl laine du Juif merci la parole est
à Madame Prisc porte-parole du
gouvernement merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député permettez-moi de vous
répondre au nom du gouvernement il y a 4
mois le 7 octobre
2023 des vies ont été violemment arraché
par la folie terroriste le 7 octobre
2023 l'horreur surgissait à nouveau dans
le quotidien des Israéliens le 7 octobre
2023 commençait l'inéluctable souffrance
des familles des proches et des blessés
le 7 octobre 2023 une attaque
terroristes des plus barbares a été mené
par le Hamas contre l'État d'Israël
contre des israélien contre des Français
contre des Juifs monsieur le député
pardà nos divergences politiques il y a
des moments qui nous appellent
collectivement à la hauteur l'hommage
national voulu par le Président de la
République fait partie de ces moments
demain nous devons nous souvenir
ensemble des noms et des visages de
celles et ceux qui ont été arrachés par
le à leur famille si le protocole
prévoit d'inviter tous les responsables
politiques chacun chacun appréciera
l'opportunité ou non de sa présence
puisque les familles se sont exprimées
je tiens ici une nouvelle fois à dire
que justifier le terrorisme c'est
accepté qu'il frappe à
nouveau je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Lionel
Tivoli pour le rassemblement national
oui madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à Bruno
Le Maire ministre de l'Économie monsieur
ministre après l'augmentation du tarif
du gaz en janvier qui fait suite à la
fin du bouclier tarifaire une nouvelle
augmentation à compté du 1er juillet
voilà le terrible cadeau d'anniversaire
que vous offrirez aux Français pour
célébrer les 1 an de la fin des tarifs
réglementés entre 5,5 % et 10,4 %
d'augmentation sur le gaz au 1er juillet
2024 c'est donc ce nouveau cadeau que
vous allez offrir aux Français quelques
jours seulement après leur avoir offert
une augmentation de 10 % sur les tarifs
de l'électricité plus inro incroyable
encore une ex-ministre de vorant
justifie que cette augmentation je cite
serait bénéfique pour le pouvoir d'achat
des ménages et est dû en parti grâce à
eux puisque la consommation
diminue monsieur le ministre très
sérieusement de qui vous moquez-vous
c'est à l'exploitant d'assumer le risque
et non pas au consommateurs
contrairement à votre ancienne collègue
aujourd'hui présidente de la Commission
de régulation de l'énergie aucun
Français ne se réjouira de cette
nouvelle ponction votre soumission aux
instances européennes au libre échange
est la seule responsable de l'ex de
l'explosion du prix du gaz le marché
européen de l'énergie conduit à un
alourdissement des importations
françaises et à l'aggravation de la
dépendance envers cette énergie nous
plaçant sous la tutelle de puissances
étrangères n'hésitant à aucun moment de
nous faire payer le prix fort de ces
armments politiques monsieur le ministre
les Français sont à bout de ces
augmentations successives le marché
européen de l'énergie est un boulet dans
le pouvoir d'achat de nos ménages quand
allez-vous donc rompre avec les règles
de ce marché pour fixer le prix du gaz
quand allez-vous enfin défendre in frçis
et uiser Touty de PR pour déjouer les
effets spécula des March qu allezv
concéder à baisser la TVA à 5 sur les
énergies je vous remercie je la Paro est
Monsieur Bro minist de l'économie des
finan de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique madame la présidenteur députés
monsieurp pr du
gaz c'est surtout votre soumission aux
intérêts étrangers de la Russie qui a
fait exploser les prix du gaz mais
mesdames et messieurs les députés du
rassemblement national les faits sont
têttu les prix du gaz étaient à 80 €
avant l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la
Russie ils ont bondi à 200 € le
lendemain de l'intervention de Vladimir
Poutine que vous avez soutenu contre
l'Ukraine vous avez systématiquement
pris parti de l'étranger de la Russie et
de vladir ptine contre les intérêts de
la nation française nous avons protégé
les consommateurs vous avez défendu vos
amis de
l'étranger quant à la protection du
consommateur monsieur le député vous me
poser pour la Xè fois la même question
je vais vous apporter la même réponse là
où vous avez proposé une baisse de la
TVA qui aurait représenté généreusement
peut-être 200 à 300 € d'économie par an
pour le consommateur nous nous avons on
mis en place un bouclier sur
l'électricité et sur le gaz qui a pris
en charge la moitié de la facture du
consommateur vous êtes du côté de
l'étranger contre la nation du côté du
producteur contre le consommateur voilà
la réalité du rassemblement
national je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député excusez-moi
monsieur le ministre mais le champion
d'importation du GNL rus c'est vous et
c'est votre
gouvernement
je vous remercie pour le groupe
Renaissance la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane
bouchou
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui cela fait 16 jours que les
pêcheurs du golfe de Gascogne sont à
quais ce sont plus de 450 bateaux
concernés par l'interdiction de pêche
pendant 1 mois 65 en Vendé C fermeture
spatiau temporelle est vécu à la fois
comme une sanction et comme une
injustice une sanction parce que s'il y
a bien une profession qui s'est adapté
qui a su rebondir et se réinventer c'est
la pêche installation de caméras
embarquées dispositifs d'effarouchement
coopération avec les scientifiques une
injustice parce qu'il s'agit de capture
accidentelles et que pas un pêcheur ne
part en mer avec la volonté de tuer des
petits CAC après les les crises à
répétition et les baisses de quôas
décidé en fin d'année dernière c'est un
nouveau coup de Massu bien entendu je
veux saluer ici l'accompagnement de
l'État et les aides annoncées par le
gouvernement mais dans les port le
sentiment de résignation prédomine
monsieur le ministre les pêcheurs
veulent vivre de leur métier pas des
aides aujourd'hui nous devons proposer
des solutions qui permettent que
pêcheurs et cétacés cohabitent et que
nous n'ayons pas à choisir entre les uns
ou les autres pour cela nous devons
répondre au défi de la réduction des
captures et de la préservation d'une
activité et qui monsieur le ministre
comme notre agriculture devrait devenir
un secteur d'activité hautement protégé
je devrais même dire sanctuirisé nous le
devons à nos pêcheurs parce que la pêche
c'est à la fois notre histoire nos
paysages et le poumon de nos économies
locales un emploi en mer génère TR à
quat emplois sur terre pendant ce mois
de fermeture dans ma circonscription la
crée de Saint-Gil croix vie va perdre
600000 € de chiffre d'affaires pour cell
des Sables d'Olonne c'est Mo- 50 % de
débarque de poisson par semaine
monsieur le ministre vous avez rencontré
le Comité national des pêches la semaine
dernière que leur avez-vous dit et
quelles sont les perspectives pour que
la pêche française et toute la filière
puisse toujours se conjuguer au futur je
vous remercie je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur Christophe béch ministre
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les député
monsieur le député Stéphan
bchou
oui la pêche partie notre souveraineté
alimentaire insuffisamment puisque 70 %
du poisson que nous consommons en France
est importé et je sais à la fois la
réalité des difficultés des pêcheurs et
le soutien constant au travers des
crises successives qu'ils ont eu à
affronter que le gouvernement leur a
apporté je pense au covid mais je pense
au brexit qui a particulièrement impacté
la pêche française et bien sûr à la
hausse des prix de l'énergie qui a
conduit à un certain nombre de décision
le 22 décembre dernier le Conseil d'État
a considéré que que les dispositifs de
préservation de lutte contre les
captures accidentelles étaient
insuffisants nous avons vécu l'année
dernière avec près de 2500 captures
accidentelles dans 1482 pendant le seul
hiver des projections qui menacent la
survie de l'espèce des dauphins et des
marsoins communs parce qu'à 2500 prises
c'est entre 5000 et 10000 dauphins qui
sont menacés au-delà des taux qui sont
acceptables pour autant la fermeture
spatio-temporelle de tous les bateaux de
plus de 8 m dans une zone aussi
importante du 22 janvier au 20 février
ne peut pas ne pas être massivement
accompagné par les pouvoirs publics le
1er février dernier devant le Comité
national des pêches j'ai dit quoi 1 que
ce début de semaine hier 5 février nous
aurions l'accord de la Commission
européenne pour un déblocage rapide des
aides hier nous avons effectivement
comme je l'avais dit franchi un cap
technique crucial sur les niveaux
d'indemnisation qui permet de vous
confirmer que le 20 février nous
ouvrirons les guichets d'aide pour que
les paiements puissent arriver au début
du mois de mars je précise que ce
dispositif vaut pour les bateaux
concernés mais qu'un dispositif
spécifique pour le marayage sur les
pertes au titre de l'excédent brut
d'exploitation et regarder et qu'en
collaboration avec les élus locaux je
continue discuter avec les ports
lescriers je me rendrai en fin de
semaine à la rencontre de l'ensemble des
acteurs merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole à monsieurï pour le
groupe la
franceçmise merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous
déclariez ici il y a une semaine avec
assurance vouloir faire rimer climat et
croissance c'était votre dernière
trouvaille vous avez appelé ça
l'écologie à la française aujourd'hui
c'est votre ami le pétrolier vermillon
qui va inaugurer ce nouveau concept
c'est avec votre bénédiction qu'il
s'apprête à faire de nouveaux forages
autour du bassin d'Arcachon ce projet
est la définition parfaite du mot
incohérence madame born déclarait en
juillet 2022 vouloir faire de la France
la première grande nation industrielle à
s'émanciper des énergies fossiles les
experts du GEC disent que tout nouveau
projet d'extraction est incompatible
avec un réchauffement de la planète à
moin de 1,5 degr mais vous vous regardez
passif la pous ouverture de H nouveaux
puits de pétrole au cœur de la forêt de
La Teste de Buc en
Gironde ironie cruelle cette forêt
usagère pense encore les plai des
incendies dévastateurs de l'été
2022 vos arguments je les connais mieux
vaut du pétrole local que du pétrole
importé c'est donc ça l'écologie à la
française que vous nous ventier ici même
la semaine dernière polluant oui mais
polluant français dé is la biodiversité
mais détruisons français vous aurez
ainsi la fierté cocardière d'avoir
dépassé les dernières limites planétaire
avec un désastre bleu blanc
rouge alors je vous le demande
solennellement Monsieur le Premier
Ministre pour répondre de vos
engagements passés pour répondre à
l'urgence climatique pour répondre aux
citoyens et citoyennes qui seront
mobilisés contre ce projet dimanche
prochain à Bordeaux allez vous faire
prvoir la protection de l'environnement
et la lutte contre le changement
climatique avant les intérêts financiers
allez-vous sans tergiverser exiger
l'interdiction de ces nouveaux forages
en pleine
forêt je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député
prudom c'est dans ce pays
dans cet hémicycle que le 30 décembre
2017 l'Assemblée nationale avec une
majorité fidèle au président de la
République a décidé pour la première
fois d'interdire les nouveaux ferrages
pétroliers et de dire qu'en 2040 en
France il n'y aurait plus de forrage
d'hydrocarbur à aucun moment la gauche
dont vous vous réclamez n'avait utilisé
les mandats qu'elle avait eu pour
prendre ce type de décision la loi elle
fixe un cadre celui de 2040 et elle
indique qu'entre les deux il y a une
publque qui s'est déroulé au mois de
septembre et une décision qui est
désormais attendue de la part du préfet
Guillot à l'issue du cerste mais parlons
d'incohérence et de cohérence il va
falloir monsieur prudom que vous nous
expliquiez où est votre cohérence quand
la nôtre et précisément de sortir des
énergies fossiles et d'assumer que c'est
par davantage de renouvelablebl et de
nucléaire qu'on arrivera à sortir des
énergies fossiles vous êtes-vous dans
une position qui consiste à défendre à
l'international les dictateurs qui
proposent d'imposer au Guyana au
Venezuela de nouveaux forages pétroliers
à hauteur de 11 milliards de baril et à
reprocher qu'en France dans le cadre des
lois existantes des dépôts de demandes
d'autorisation soient fait vous dénoncez
de manière régulière l'inaction mais
quand on vous propose de voter des
dispositifs vous expliquez toujours que
c'est trop peu ou que ça n'est pas assez
soutenez la transition écologique à la
française assumez la relance du
nucléaire fait fait en sorte de nous
accompagner sur les énergies
renouvelables sortez de votre confort et
de vos postures parce qu'en la matière
il va être tempant que vous alliez forer
de nouvelles idées que celles que vous
tentez de nous
recycler merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à présent à
Monsieur Nicolas metzdorf pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
Renaissance merci merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Maire le ministre de
l'économie et des finances
monsieur le ministre la Calédonie repose
sur son nickel c'est 97 % de nos
exportations c'est 13000 emplois direct
et indirect qui représente 20 % des
cotisations qui vont à notre sécurité
sociale malheureusement nous avons subi
ces derniers temps la concurrence des
Chinois qui ont investi massivement en
Indonésie et qui mettent en péril nos
usines vous êtes venu accompagné de
Géral armanin il y a quelques mois
présenter le pacte nickel un accord
entre calédoniens entre l'État entre les
collectivités calédoniennes et entre les
multinationales présentes un accord pour
améliorer notre compétitivité et sauver
nos
usines si les choses semblent aller dans
le bon sens pour les deux usines du Sud
malgré des efforts à consentir les
choses sont plus compliquées pour
l'usine du Nord qui se trouve dans ma
circonscription c'est 1300 emplois
directs qui sont menacés de
fermeture cette difficulté à sauver
l'usine du Nord réside principalement
dans l'ABS sens de décision et
d'ouverture du président de la province
Nord simplement monsieur le ministre
nous devons faire tous les efforts
possibles pour pouvoir sauver ses
emplois c'est une semaine décisive qui
s'est ouverte à Paris et vous avez
entamé des discussions de haut niveau
avec la multinationale présente et
l'ensemble des acteurs calédoniens
pouvez-vous aujourd'hui indiquer au
250000 français de Nouvelle-Calédonie
qui nous regardent à 2h du matin en
direct quelles sont les évolutions de ce
dossier et si nous allons parvenir à
ouvrir des perspectives positives
l'industrie du nckel en
Nouvelle-Calédonie je vous remercie je
vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'Économie des Finances de
la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député
metzdorf je veux être très clair avec
vous je crois et nous croyons tous avec
le Premier ministre avec le président de
la République avec cette majorité à
l'avenir de la filière nickel en
Nouvelle Calédonie je me suis rendu sur
place nous avons visité ensemble les
trois usines usin du Sud l'usine de
numea et l'usine KNS du Nord donc il
faut construire l'avenir de la filière
nickel en nouvelle caïon mais il y a
pour ça trois conditions que j'ai
présenté à Nea que j'ai répété à tous
les élus et que je vais vous redire cet
après-midi la première c'est que
l'ensemble des élus s'engage dans le
pacte nickel avec un accord qui
permettra de mieux exploiter la
ressource minière de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et d'en exporter une
partie pour avoir de la trésorerie
supplémentaire pour rendre nos usine
plus compétitive c'est la première
condition et j'appelle tous les élus à
signer ce projet d'accord sur lequel
nous travaillons maintenant depuis
plusieurs semaines pour mieux exploiter
les ressources minières de la Nouvelle
Calédonie la deuxième condition c'est
qu'il y ait un soutien de l'État pour
moderniser le réseau électrique de la
Nouvelle Calédonie avoir un prix de
l'énergie qui soit moins élevé le
président de la République a pris des
engagements j'ai pris des engagements à
l'occasion de mon déplacement nous
sommes prêts à investir dans le réseau
énergétique de la Nouvelle-Calédonie
mais la trème condition elle est claire
et je la rappelle ici il faut qu'il y
ait des industriels une usine ne peut
pas fonctionner sans industriel et
l'État ne se substituera pas aux
industriels j'ai fait des propositions à
glencor pour l'usine du Nord n avons
proposé 60 millions d'euros de
subvention sur le prix d'énergie nous
avons proposé 45 millions d'euros de
ressources supplémentaires nous avons
proposé un près de 100 million d'euros
200 millions d'euros pour la seule usine
du Nord pour garantir sa pérenité sous
forme de soutien public maintenant c'est
aux actionnaires de prendre leur
responsabilité nous n'irons pas plus
loin et nous nallons pas subventionner à
perte Glencore et la province du Nord
ont leur responsabilité à prendre l'État
a pris les siennes il n'ira pas plus
loin car c'est l'argent du contribuable
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur metzdorf
oui merci madame la Présidente je salue
l'action du ministre tout le long de la
semaine qui s'est mobilisé pour sauver
nos usines nous nous rendrons avec le
président Mayard à nomé à dès demain
pour continuer à orienter les
discussions je vous remercie merci
beaucoup la séance des questions au
Gouvernement est terminée la séance est
suspendue